ah shoot get down all right
yeah I think so Thanks you can thank me
later when we're safe
reliving familiar frights can often make
for a lesson exciting horror experience
but with the remake of Resident Evil 2
Capcom shows respect for the original
while also going to great lengths to
give their macabre atmosphere intense
gameplay a noticeable upgrade in doing
so this revamp of the classic survival
horror game shows that the series still
offers a terrifying experience like no
other
yes stay here it's not safe I'll meet
you at the station
I'll be there you once again play as
either Leon Kennedy or Claire Redfield
during a deadly outbreak in record city
with hordes of zombies and other
grotesque monsters unleashed throughout
the city the two protagonists will
experience their own series of harrowing
encounters throughout the larger story
Resident Evil 2 is very much a game
about escalation as your resources
dwindle and the monsters become more
fearsome and elaborate the pressure is
constantly mounting as the plot
progresses even the smallest of
victories can feel like a major win in
Resident Evil 2 but you'll often find
yourself moving on to the next struggle
before you know it
after finishing the first playthrough
you can follow up with the second
scenario allowing you to see the other
side of the larger story though each
scenario largely covers the same ground
and choices therein won't impact the
other what makes them worthwhile are the
different encounters and subplots that
happen for particular characters which
you won't see for the other hey it's
okay I promise
the remake is a stellar mix of the
understated survivalist approach from
the original games and along with the
fluid and responsive controls for more
recent entries though many locations and
their layouts are similar save for the
addition of a brand new area and a new
monster to deal with the events therein
are different when recognizable scenes
happen they often play out in radically
different ways though early games in the
series have a reputation for coming off
as melodramatic the remake presents a
more believable plot that maintains its
poise it's also propped up by some
impressive writing and strong
performances to help convey a palpable
sense of urgency and despair some of the
game's more poignant moments are given
to minor characters including the doomed
police lieutenant Marvin Brenner this is
good news we can get you to a hospital
no no I am NOT the priority here
lieutenant I'm not just gonna leave you
here I'm giving you an order wookie you
save yourself first I've come with you
but I just slow you down the more
serious tone is further enhanced by the
renewed fantastically atmospheric
presentation which uses its impeccable
audio and visual design sense to create
an eerie dreadful vibe you rarely feel
safe in Resident Evil 2 even when you
actually are
the remakes impressive level of detail
is especially noticeable during the many
gruesome encounters which channel the
same macaw and methodical approach from
the classics though Resident Evil 2
easily proves to be the goriest game of
the series it never comes off as
excessive and it all serves to highlight
the grisly details in the survival
horror experience as the zombies are the
one constant threat throughout you'll
quickly become accustomed to seeing
their flesh chip away their bodies fall
over onto your character or get torn in
half by well-placed shotgun blasts
however even when partially disabled by
critical hits creatures can still attack
when you least expect it though you'll
likely settle into tactics that work
well including barricading certain
windows or simply evading common threats
Resident Evil 2 has its ways to amp up
the challenge
Jesus Christ in one of the game's more
tense encounters you cross paths with
the tyrant an opposing force of nature
and a persistent threat that actively
stalks you this dynamic adds serious
pressure to certain situations making
some of the common foes you've gotten a
handle of become genuine threats once
again though the tyrant is an effective
stressor during key moments which can
make getting the best of it all the more
satisfying there are times where it can
disrupt the overall pacing this is
especially frustrating when you're
trying to accomplish minor objectives in
crowded spaces which should be tense
encounters can sometimes become annoying
exercises in trying to lure it away
sometimes taking advantage of the
tyrants rather limited AI to do just
that
while the remake often keeps seeing
serious it's not all doom and gloom in
addition to occasional references that
break the tension there's also a suite
of unlockable content catered to
hardcore fans including the classic
outfits for both Leon and Claire
after completing the campaign for both
characters the bonus mode starring fan
favorites hunk and tofu will unlock
these timed encounters allow for a
chance to cut loose battling against
hordes of monsters without the worry
from the larger survival horror
mechanics from the main game Resident
Evil 2 is not only a stellar remake of
the original but it's also simply a
strong horror game that delivers anxiety
inducing and grotesque situations
topping some of the series's finest
entries but above all the remake is an
impressive game for the fact that it
goes all in on the pure survival horror
experience confidently embracing his
horrifying tone rarely letting up until
the story's conclusion though Resident
Evil 2 as its roots firmly in the past
it reworks the familiar Horrors into
something that feels brand-new and all
its own
[Music]
[Music]